autumn carpets the hillsides the
multi-hued canopy marking the seasonal
change of millennia
ancient original forest sweeping across
the carpathian mountains in eastern
europe
if the amazon rainforest is the lungs of
the world and the forests of the
carpathian mountains are the lungs of
europe they suck the co2 out of the
atmosphere and put oxygen back into it
they regulate the water system there's a
vast vast array of life here in fact the
forests of the world are the most
biodiverse ecosystems on the planet
but in this once pristine environment
life has been squeezed out by the
so-called timber mafia
trees are being extracted illegally on
an unprecedented scale by criminal gangs
and the locals who fight against it paid
the price beatings are frequent but
people are murdered too six forest
rangers have been killed in the last few
years
leading to recent protests in the
capital bucharest
[Music]
forester horia petrus mimics the call of
a red stag
he tells me there used to be 50 or 60 in
this area alone
and this is why
this area was illegally logged 10 years
ago and it ripped apart the ecosystem
you can see this kind of devastation
from the moon on the satellite
maps you you can see everything it's
impossible to believe that they didn't
know they know and they they encouraged
and they took a lot of money horia says
it's clear who's to blame
the politicians
we spoke to the government and they told
us
combating illegal logging is one of the
priorities of romania it's a continuous
action and we've already seen results
for the people who live in the mountains
it's terrible
for hundreds of years we have managed
the forest in a sustainable way we take
a small amount of wood for building and
fire it's very annoying that strangers
come here from other countries and take
away our way of life i'm frightened of
the people who steal the wood i feel my
family is in danger because this is a
mob-like organization
the scale of loss is staggering romania
loses up to nine hectares of forest per
hour to illegal logging that contributes
to the huge amount of forest lost
globally in fact between 1990 and 2016
the world lost 1.3 million square
kilometers of forest an area larger than
south africa
and in 2020 tropical forest loss around
the world equaled the size of the
netherlands
since humans started cutting down
forests 46 of trees have been felled
around the world 2020 was meant to be a
landmark year in the fight against
deforestation a year by which many
countries had pledged to halve or
completely stop forest loss
but in fact the plundering has increased
here in romania it's not too late yet
but if not now
when
nick clark al jazeera carpathian
mountains romania
okay let's bring in thales cavalio
resende who's an expert at the unesco
world heritage center he joins us live
from paris thanks for joining us thales
can you tell us it seems
counter-intuitive that these world
heritage
forests are actually carbon
emitters can you explain how that's
happened
yeah indeed um
we did this very first
analysis in which we were able to
quantify
the amount of carbon
that is absorbed and released from world
heritage forests
um
we were kind of surprised both
positively and negatively
of the results we found out that indeed
world heritage forests are a large
carbon sink
absorbing
190 million tons of co2 per year that's
more or less
half of the uk's annual emissions from
fossil fuels but also
unfortunately that
10
world heritage forests have
emitted more carbon than
captured
and the reasons i would say
are mainly land use pressures but also
climate change that is concerning and
tell us why the carpathian mountains are
bucking that trend and managing to suck
up much of europe's co2 gases why is
that the case
well
i guess the the case of the carpathians
is um
something that can be
seen uh all around the world know
with in times of climate change
and the capacity of forests to
absorb carbon it can be reduced and
what
is alarming is the fact that in the
future more sites can be
at risk because of this
so how big of a problem is deforestation
globally and how can we can we at all
reverse these um
these issues that we've created
well actually what struck us more
in this study was
the impacts of climate-related events
for instance some wildfires
we have seen unprecedented wildfires
over the past few years which for
instance one single uh wi-fi released
more uh co2 emissions than a country uh
per year
and
and this is quite uh
alarming because it's a vicious cycle
though as you have
more
higher temperatures this means more
wildfires more welfares more co2
emissions and then more co2 emissions
again uh higher temperatures so it's a
vicious cycle that can be very
dangerous
yes and we keep getting the same message
over and over again about climate change
thank you for your insights tales
cavalio resende appreciate your time
thank you very much have a very good day